le black friday et ses promos en tous
genres c'est la journée idéale pour les
à des actes d'achats compulsifs
j'aime beaucoup acheté pour demain pour
aujourd'hui pour toujours j'adore
acheter tout et n'importe quoi
ce trouble à un nom l'hogneau manille
s'est passé je suis un besoin quoi j'ai
besoin de d'acheter pour ces acheteurs
compulsifs pas de limite de dépense pas
de but particulier juste une envie celle
de dépenser toujours plus cette
addiction est apparue au début des
années 60 en france avec l'émergence de
la société de consommation des vêtements
des bijoux du maquillage ou encore des
livres
absolument tout y passe en 1982 cette
jeune parisienne a jeté son dévolu sur
des chaussures internet a commencé sa
collection à quelles périodes
ça fait cinq six ans debré 5 6 ans tan
dung combien 180 ml sont répartis un peu
partout
cette frénésie des achats compulsifs
peut avoir des conséquences parfois
certaines personnes se surendette les
profils sont variés des hommes des
femmes des jeunes aux personnes âgées
les ouvriers des cadres déjà un problème
pour sap ou même pas un problème je peux
être amoureuse et pita que je vais et
claquer un peu plus que j'ai pas
forcément des grandes sommes mais plus
que j'ai en fait je fais du mal pour
lutter contre cette addiction
certaines associations voient le jour
comme les débiteurs anonyme
seule condition pour y adhérer s'engager
à rembourser ses dettes
dans ce programme en fait on a pensé
on apprend à découvrir soi c'est à dire
que l'argent l'endettement compulsifs ou
les achats compulsifs c'est un symptôme
d'un malaise plus profond
aujourd'hui l'onu aux manies et reconnue
juridiquement en france une expertise
psychiatrique peut démontrer l'atteinte
de ce trouble près des tribunaux pour
faire annuler des dépenses
[Musique]